now to the record number of new
coronavirus cases more than 83
000 were reported on friday that number
was nearly matched on saturday before
falling to more than 60 thousand on
sunday
when fewer cases are normally reported
our lead national correspondent david
begno
is in new jersey where the governor just
extended
a public health emergency david why are
officials there so concerned
well anthony the governor says they're
seeing levels here in new jersey that
they haven't seen since back in
may but i want to start deep in the
heart of texas in el paso
near the border because this morning
they're back on lockdown
el paso accounts for 20 of
all the coronavirus cases in the state
of texas right now
these are the newly assembled tents at
university medical center of el paso
where the icu is now full so is every
icu across el paso county
to get control of the outbreak county
officials have issued a stay-at-home
order
and a nightly curfew the only people who
are exempt
are those going to work the reasons for
the new order
have to do with the that we're at a
crisis stage
coronavirus cases are rising in 44
states
no states are seeing declines and in the
last two weeks
half of all the u.s states have set
single day records for new cases
the white house coronavirus task force
coordinator dr debra burks
says that outbreaks are accelerating
because asymptomatic spreaders
are going to visit friends and family
the future does
look devastating right now for the
number of cases that we see
the potential of the rising cases
but we can stop that community spread if
we work together
even as new cases rise some americans
are still dealing with the lingering
side effects
these are the so-called coveted
long-haulers like maggie flannery
the 12-year-old from new york city
caught the virus back in march
and has experienced extreme fatigue and
shortness of breath
ever since then amy wilson is her mom
there is something between um you know
the icu
and asymptomatic there's this weird
middle ground where you don't want to be
so what
whatever people can do to take
precautions continues to be worth it
and so what do you say to parents who
say listen i'm not really worried
because my kids are young
the numbers are with you but the risk
isn't
zero covet is not something you want to
get
and the more we hear about these covet
long haulers it's not just young people
like maggie it's adults and even elderly
people
and you know gail one thing that was
interesting uh beyond other things that
maggie's mom said is that if maggie goes
to school on monday and she climbs a
flight of stairs
the fatigue she experiences is not just
monday
it could last throughout the entire week
that's what's so scary about this david
thank you very much